[Musik]
du bist das mund zurück und was gibt es
bei dir neues niveau wird bald bei jahre
an fahrradladen eine ausbildung macht
wirklich das ist center das wird eine
harte zeit
das weiß hoffentlich wie so jara ist
eine harte schaffen
du wirst tag und nacht arbeiten müssen
bei uns wäre das anders gewesen der das
meiste zeit deines lebens haben last
denn nichts einreden
das stimmt zumindest im winter im sommer
ist wegen der vielen gäste draußen der
betrieb aber im winter ist es ein paar
alanya auch ruhiger wegen des wetters
verfasst mit anfragen
du wirst nicht wundern wir zumindest
fahren bei schnee und eis mit dem
fahrrad muss tut uns leid nico aber du
wirst nie wieder freizeit haben dafür
gibt es im sommer wegen der hitze am
mittag eines fiesta in spanien
vielleicht du wirst deine gewohnheiten
ändern müssen also ich finds ich
versuche ja vielleicht machen wir eine
siesta dann können wir nie kunst
fahrradladen besuchen denn er muss mit
als arbeiten
ich weiß nicht was mit den leuten los
ist zu bearbeiten
[Musik]